Der erste Impfstoff
gegen das Coronavirus
ist von Swissmedic zugelassen.
Ich würde mich nicht impfen lassen.
Impfen oder nicht impfen?
- Ich würde auf jeden Fall impfen.
Ich bin sehr negativ eingestellt,
was die Impfung angeht.
Ich würde mich impfen lassen.
Ich vertraue der Wirtschaft ...
... äh, der Wissenschaft.
Kann man das rausschneiden?
Es ist die grösste Impfaktion,
die es in der Schweiz je gegeben hat,
diese COVID-19-Impfung.
Darf ich etwas fragen? Hallo.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
was in den Impfdosen drin ist.
Ich würde etwas warten und schauen,
was die Nebenwirkungen sind.
Ich halte es für sinnvoll,
wenn sich v.a. die Alten impfen,
weil sie am meisten gefährdet sind.
Die Nebenwirkungen der Erkrankung
sind viel schlimmer.
Es kann sein, dass es etwas brennt.
Schon fast vorbei. Achtung, Stich!
Dann sehen wir Sie in vier Wochen
wieder, für die zweite Impfung.
Ja, wenn ich noch lebe.
- Ja, sicher.
(Französisch)
Es gibt eine Macht auf dieser Welt,
welche die Menschheit
kontrollieren will.
Brauchst du keinen Beweis
für so etwas?
Wie sollte ich Ihnen das beweisen?
In unseren Augen
ist die Diktatur zu verhindern.
Die will ja, glaube ich, niemand.
(Demonstranten) # Freiheit, Freiheit
ist das Einzige, was zählt.
Die Menschen müssen lernen,
damit umzugehen.
Die Pandemie ist real.
Es muss jeder selber wissen.
Man kann niemanden zwingen. - Gut.
Ich mache, was ich will,
nicht, was der Bundesrat sagt.
Gruss an Alain Berset.
Wir sind unterwegs in diesem Land
und wollen wissen:
Was macht diese Impfung mit uns?
* Ruhige Musik *
Wir warten hier auf die Impfequipe.
Die mobile Impfequipe,
die jetzt hier im Alters-
und Pflegeheim Eigen in Faulensee
im Kanton Bern impfen kommen sollte.
Grüezi miteinander.
- Guten Morgen.
Supersaxo.
- Supersaxo und Frau Bundi.
Genau.
- Grüezi.
Sie meldeten sich beide freiwillig,
um hier zu impfen?
Ja, wir arbeiten eigentlich nicht
fürs Spital Thun.
Ich bin Anästhesiearzt in Bern,
aber gerade nicht voll ausgelastet,
weil wir reduzierte Programme haben.
Wir begleiten Sie einfach ...
- Ja.
... und schauen zu, was Sie machen.
- Super.
Also, legen wir los.
- Gut.
Wie viele Dosen
haben Sie jetzt da?
Das sind 50 Impfdosen,
gekühlt auf 4 °C.
Es ist Anfang Januar.
Seit einer Woche
wird im Kanton Bern geimpft.
Wir freuen uns, sind Sie da.
Schauen wir mal, was es braucht.
Erst ein Impfstoff ist zu diesem
Zeitpunkt in der Schweiz zugelassen.
Die Nachfrage
ist weit grösser als das Angebot.
Die Kontingente, die wir kriegen,
werden vom Kanton gesteuert.
Wir versuchen einfach,
jeden Tropfen zu nutzen.
Jede einzelne Dosis
auch zu verimpfen.
Wir hoffen, es bleibt so und gibt
mit der Zeit dann mehr Impfstoff.
Will ich mich impfen lassen
oder nicht?
Diesen Entscheid mussten
alle Bewohner und Angestellten
dieses Heims
schon Tage im Voraus fällen.
(Frau) Alle wurden informiert,
damit sich jeder
Gedanken machen kann,
ob die Impfung für ihn infrage kommt
oder nicht.
Bei uns wird der freie Entscheid
bzw. Wille berücksichtigt
und es wurden auch alle informiert,
dass es keine Restriktionen gibt,
dass der Wille
wirklich auch akzeptiert wird.
* Ruhige Musik *
Es ist ein neuartiger,
genbasierter Impfstoff -
eine sog. mRNA-Impfung.
Entwickelt
wurde sie innerhalb eines Jahres.
So schnell,
wie noch keine Impfung zuvor.
Können Sie die Skepsis gegenüber dem,
was Sie vorbereiten, verstehen?
Verstehen, ja.
Aber ich denke, es ist ...
... nicht gerechtfertigt.
So viel Vertrauen darf man ...
... in die Medizin, die Pharmazie
und in die, welche den Impfstoff
entwickelt haben, haben.
Es gibt ja auch kritische Stimmen.
Denen könnte man auch vertrauen.
Darf ich zuerst die Impfung ...
- Sicher. Entschuldigung.
Seit jeher skeptisch gegenüber
Impfungen ist das Pflegepersonal.
Gemäss Umfragen hat die Pflege
auch gegenüber der Corona-Impfung
grosse Vorbehalte.
Ich will wissen,
ob es Heime oder Spitäler gibt,
die ihre Pflegenden
deswegen unter Druck setzen.
Mhm. Gut, aber eben ...
Trotzdem gibt es ein Grundrecht
auf Unversehrtheit des Körpers.
In einer Regionalzeitung
werde ich fündig.
Da heisst es tatsächlich
von dem Heim:
"Ob die Impfung im Heim
obligatorisch sein wird oder nicht,
will der Vorstand
diese Woche entscheiden."
Ich frage beim Heim nach,
ob bereits entschieden wurde.
Grüezi, da ist Winzenried
vom Schweizer Fernsehen.
Obwohl Bund und Kantone
ein Obligatorium derzeit ablehnen,
können private Arbeitgeber
eine Impfpflicht einführen.
Rechtlich heikel, aber machbar.
Gut, dann verbleiben wir so.
Sie geben mir Bescheid,
ob Sie uns noch erläutern,
warum Sie
diesen Entscheid gefällt haben -
sei es mündlich oder schriftlich.
Okay, vielen Dank. Auf Wiederhören!
Das Heim hat sich tatsächlich
dazu entschieden,
den Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
diesen Vertrag vorzulegen:
Entweder impfen sie sich oder sie
müssen mit einer Kündigung rechnen.
Das ist meines Wissens das erste Heim
in der Schweiz, das das so macht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Wir sind auf dem Weg
zu einer Gruppierung,
die sich "Freunde der Verfassung"
nennt.
Das ist eine Gruppierung,
die die Massnahmen des Bundes bezüg-
lich Corona grundsätzlich ablehnt.
Grüezi, Herr Bubendorf.
Ich muss etwas vorbereiten.
Ich ziehe mich um.
Ich mache das dort drüben,
wo es geschützt ist.
Michael Bubendorf,
Sprecher der Verfassungsfreunde,
demonstriert gegen die Maskenpflicht
auf seine Art.
Wir versuchen es damit,
dass wir uns so maskieren,
wie es aktuell erlaubt ist,
aber wir treiben es ins Absurde.
Okay.
Sie lehnen die Impfpflicht ab,
aber auch die Impfempfehlung,
sehe ich das richtig?
Wir lehnen Impfempfehlungen
nicht grundsätzlich ab.
Aber wir finden,
in der aktuellen Situation,
mit einem sehr schnell zugelassenen
Virus ... äh ... Impfstoff
und sehr wenigen Daten und Fakten
müsste man mit Impfempfehlungen
mit grösster Vorsicht vorgehen
und auch auf die Risiken hinweisen.
Das wird ja gemacht.
- Was uns am allerwichtigsten ist:
dass man die Krankheitsgeschichten
der Leute miteinbezieht.
Die Gruppe der Verfassungsfreunde ist
jung: Es gibt sie seit sechs Monaten.
Zwei Referenden
haben sie schon zustande gebracht
und bringen die Vorlagen vors Volk:
das COVID-19-Gesetz
und das Terrorgesetz.
Diese Unterschriften reichen sie
an diesem kalten Januarmorgen ein.
Wir müssen den Pavillon halten.
Wir haben hier
unseren Freund und Helfer. - Bravo.
(Alle) Bravo.
* Applaus *
Mit dem Erfolg kann man sagen,
dass im Moment
niemand an uns vorbeikommt,
wenn man ein neues Gesetz
einreichen will.
In der ganzen Schweiz merken Leute,
dass etwas im Busch ist
und dass man sich bewegen muss.
(Alle) Bravo.
Vielen Dank.
(Alle) # Freiheit ist das Einzige,
was zählt.
# Freiheit.
# Freiheit ...
# ... ist das Einzige, was zählt.
(Alle) Oh!
Das sog. Terrorgesetz
haben ursprünglich Jungparteien
wie die JUSO lanciert.
Doch diese wollen mit den Ver-
fassungsfreunden nichts zu tun haben.
Begründung der Jungsozialisten:
Die "Freunde der Verfassung"
würden das Coronavirus verharmlosen.
Gibt es für Sie COVID-19 oder nicht?
Das ist eine "bireweiche" Frage,
wenn ich das
auf gut Baseldeutsch sagen darf.
Selbstverständlich
gibt es die Krankheit COVID-19,
die schwere Verläufe haben kann.
Wir haben eine reale Bedrohung, die
man korrekt einschätzen können muss,
was unserer Regierung nicht gelingt.
- Warum gelingt es ihr nicht?
Ich denke, einer der Gründe,
warum ihr das nicht gelingt, ist,
weil sie sich nur Wissenschaftler
von einer Seite anhört,
weil sie sich dem Dialog
mit der Bevölkerung verweigert
und weil sie nicht bereit ist,
alle Wissenschaftler anzuhören,
die etwas zum Thema zu sagen haben.
Darum reagiert sie unverhältnis-
mässig, nervös und übergriffig.
Es darf in diesem Land
ja jeder etwas sagen.
Natürlich.
Die Frage ist, wird er gehört?
Haben Sie den Eindruck,
dass die kritischen Wissenschaftler,
die sagen, die Massnahmen
seien unverhältnismässig ...
Werden die gehört?
Ich sehe nicht,
wo diese Leute gehört werden.
Ich finde, wir sind in einem
Gesundheitstotalitarismus angekommen
und müssen Schlimmeres verhindern.
- Ist das nicht wahnsinnig polemisch?
Was macht es polemisch?
Dass Sie Angst schüren bei etwas, bei
dem ich zurzeit keine Grundlage sehe.
Wenn Sie
mit Ihrer Maske im Gesicht sagen,
Sie sähen den Totalitarismus nicht,
dann schauen Sie nicht sehr weit.
Man muss doch Risiken abwägen.
Was ist das Risiko für die Personen,
die wir schützen wollen?
Nämlich die gefährdeten Personen.
Können Sie das nicht nachvollziehen?
Natürlich. Ich habe auch Angst.
Ich habe sogar grosse Angst.
Wovor? - Vor dem übergriffigen Staat,
der mein ganzes Leben durchdringt.
Ja.
Grüezi.
Ich habe einen vollen Kopf von dem,
was ich gehört habe.
Ich denke, ich hatte längst nicht
eine Antwort oder eine Frage
auf all das, was mir gesagt wurde.
Sicher ist: Das Vertrauen
in diese Institution ...
... in die Regierung, ist von den
Verfassungsfreunden massiv gestört.
Ich frage mich,
wie viele Menschen in diesem Land
im Moment ähnlich empfinden.
Menschen, die die Verfassung hoch-
heben, schlecht behandelt werden ...
Es scheint, als gäbe es seit Corona
keine Gewissheiten mehr.
(Bundi) Sie können mir sicher
Ihr Geburtsdatum verraten, oder?
9.1.1934
- Wunderbar, tipptopp.
(Supersaxo)
Hatten Sie heute Morgen kein Fieber?
Wie?
- Kein Fieber heute Morgen?
Bier?
- Nein, Fieber.
Ah, Fieber. Nein.
- Gut.
Warum wollen Sie sich impfen lassen?
- Aus Sicherheitsgründen.
Den Ellenbogen abstützen.
Also, sicher ist man ja nie.
Aber ich denke, vorbeugen ...
... ist besser als heilen.
Die mobile Impfequipe
des Kantons Bern
verabreicht den Heimbewohnern
die erste Dosis Impfstoff.
Die grosse Mehrheit der betagten
Bewohnerinnen und Bewohner hier
will sich impfen lassen.
Ging das?
- Ja, ich habe nichts gespürt.
Es ist fertig.
- Schon? Das ist gut gegangen.
In vier Wochen
kommen Sie für die zweite Impfung.
Danke.
Ade.
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Guten Tag, Supersaxo ist mein Name.
Es ist nicht anders
als eine Grippeimpfung.
Nein, nein.
Sie dürfen den Ellenbogen ablegen.
Es kann sein,
dass es ein bisschen brennt.
Ja, ja, ist gut.
- Das war's.
Das war jetzt
wirklich nicht tragisch -
wenn nicht noch etwas nachkommt.
Sie wären die Erste.
- Gut.
Darf ich Ihnen den Stock so geben?
Danke.
Wieso haben Sie Frau Balmer gesagt,
es habe noch nie jemand
auf diese Impfung reagiert?
Wir haben im Impfzentrum Thun
bis jetzt keine negativen Effekte
festgestellt.
Wir sind sehr froh, dass das so ist.
Das zeigt, dass das offenbar
ein sehr guter Impfstoff ist -
mit
sehr, sehr wenigen Nebenwirkungen.
Das Risiko ist sicher nicht null,
aber es ist sicher vertretbar.
In England gab es Reaktionen
auf diesen Impfstoff.
Wenn es darum geht,
dass Ärzte seriös informieren,
hätte man ja sagen können,
dass es schon Leute gab.
Wir hatten keine Reaktionen.
Als ich fragte, ob man auch
kritischen Stimmen vertrauen könne:
Haben Sie dafür auch Verständnis?
Beschränkt, nur beschränkt.
Ich denke,
diese Impfung ist sehr effizient.
Sie ist sehr sicher
und sie ist ein wichtiger Schritt
zur Bewältigung dieser Pandemie.
Seit einem Jahr
bestimmt ein Virus unser Leben.
Für viele kleine und mittlere Be-
triebe eine finanzielle Katastrophe.
Wir sind unterwegs in Zürich.
Wir gehen zu jemandem
aus der Gastrobranche,
den die Corona-Krise
extrem getroffen hat.
Von ihm möchte ich wissen,
ob er dank der Impfung ...
... einen Ausweg sieht.
Hallo. Ich bin Kathrin Winzenried.
- Hallo miteinander.
Ich bin Chrigi.
Chrigi Gammer?
- Genau.
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Was läuft bei Ihnen noch?
Wir müssen uns im Moment
mit Päckli-Rausgeben begnügen.
Wir hätten lieber
ein volles Restaurant, aber ...
Was heisst das? Take-away?
Josef at home, Take-away -
das ist vorbereitetes Essen.
Das muss noch in den Ofen
und ins heisse Wasser
und innerhalb weniger Minuten
hat man einen Viergänger zu Hause.
Man kann sich
das "Restauranterlebnis" holen.
Das ist jetzt für zwei Personen -
ein Fleischmenü.
Ohne Weinbegleitung.
- Das kommt in den Backofen?
Ja, es hat eine Anleitung dazu,
was man braucht.
Ein Riesenaufwand. Lohnt sich das?
- Ja ... - Ein Nullsummenspiel.
Es ist auch gut für den Ruf.
Wir sind im Gespräch in der Stadt.
Es ist wichtig, nicht drei Monate
in der Versenkung zu verschwinden
und wenn man wieder öffnen darf,
von vorne beginnen zu müssen.
Vielen steht das Wasser bis zum Hals.
Das ist bei Ihnen ...
... auch der Fall.
Mit der Härtefallregelung
warten wir noch.
Aber ich darf offen sagen:
Wir wissen nicht genau,
wie wir das Geld zusammenkriegen,
um am 20. Februar
die Löhne zu bezahlen.
Die Kurzarbeit
kommt drei bis vier Wochen später.
Ich merke schon, dass ich morgens
mit einer gewissen Unruhe aufwache.
Heute Nachmittag haben wir
mit dem Verwaltungsrat gesprochen.
Es besteht ein Druck, den ich
in meinen 15 Jahren hier nie hatte.
Eine ausserordentliche Situation.
Man hat eine soziale Verantwortung.
Man möchte
keine Mitarbeiter entlassen,
sondern sie möglichst lange
in der Kurzarbeit belassen.
Wir mussten noch niemanden
entlassen. Das wäre ein Desaster.
Irgendwann
muss man die Bilanz hinterlegen,
weil man das Geld nicht mehr hat.
Möchtest du das nehmen?
Wir bringen die Grossen raus.
Sich über Wasser halten sei das
Motto, sagt mir Christian Gammer.
Laut einer aktuellen Studie
der ETH Zürich
sehen sich 59 % aller Restaurants
in ihrer Existenz bedroht.
Olivier, bei dir alles gut?
Es gibt so viele Betriebe,
die in der gleichen Situation sind.
Die können uns ja nicht alle
pleitegehen lassen.
Wenn all die Leute
auf der Strasse stehen,
die Läden leer sind und die Mieten
nicht mehr reinkommen ...
Dann die unzähligen Zulieferer ...
Es wäre ein Desaster.
Wir versuchen,
uns bei Laune zu halten.
Es bringt ja nichts,
sich kaputtzumachen,
solange man nicht weiss,
was passiert.
Wenn er könnte,
würde er sich sofort impfen lassen,
sagt mir der Beizenchef.
Alle Masken auf.
* Er lacht. *
Tragen nicht alle Masken?
- Doch, eigentlich schon.
Aber sie rutschen über die Nase.
Der Klassiker, oder? - Grüezi.
Ist für Sie die Impfung ein Ausweg?
Es ist die grosse Hoffnung,
dass wir ein Stück weit
in die Normalität zurückkehren.
Erwarten Sie,
dass die Leute sich impfen lassen?
Ich hoffe es.
Aber erwarten kann man es nicht.
Das muss jeder
für sich selber abschätzen.
Darf ich Sie fragen?
- Ja, sicher.
Lassen Sie sich impfen?
Wenn es so weit ist,
lasse ich mich impfen.
Darf ich die andern auch noch fragen?
- Klar.
Ich habe keine Probleme
mit dieser Impfung.
Warum?
Ähm ...
Ich glaube ans Gute.
Reicht das?
- Das reicht.
Darf ich Sie fragen:
Lassen Sie sich impfen?
Eine gute Frage.
Vorläufig
kann ich noch nicht antworten.
Ehrlich gesagt, weiss ich es nicht.
Vorläufig ...
... abwarten.
Das wussten Sie nicht voneinander?
Oder wussten Sie es?
Nein, wir haben es noch nie
diskutiert, oder? - Nein.
Wir haben es angesprochen.
Aber ich finde ...
Wir reden in dem Sinne
auch nicht über Religion,
weil wir auch
so viele Religionsmeinungen haben.
Sie finden,
es gehe in die Religion rein?
Ich habe gemerkt, dass man
bei gewissen Leuten aufpassen muss.
Nicht bei uns, aber bei Gästen
sind die Meinungen sehr verschieden.
Laut einer repräsentativen Umfrage
würden sich hierzulande
im Moment 41 % impfen lassen.
Sollen die, die sich
impfen lassen können, das tun? Punkt?
Ja, ich finde,
da muss man nicht diskutieren.
Impfung, ist das für dich
kein Weg aus der Pandemie?
Das weiss ich eigentlich nicht.
Ich traue dem nicht.
Ich lasse mich auch nicht impfen.
Meine ganze Familie
arbeitet im Gesundheitswesen
und ist sehr skeptisch.
Was sagst du?
Ich glaube, es wäre okay,
die Impfung zu nehmen. - Warum?
Dann wäre der Scheiss durch
und wir könnten wieder normal leben.
Der Impfstoff
ist wirksam und sicher.
Das ist eine sehr gute Nachricht.
Ich vertraue allgemein
den Regierungen überhaupt nicht.
Denen geht es nur um Cash.
Denen geht es nur ums Geld, um den
Profit, nur um ihre scheiss Macht.
Du kannst ja wählen, dich beteiligen.
- Ja, wählen, wählen, wählen ...
Der Bundesrat macht trotzdem
den Scheiss, den er will.
Spinner gibt es überall.
Nein, Spinner nicht.
Aber es ist eine
Verschwörungstheorie, wie überall.
Ich verstehe die ganzen Bedenken,
aber man sollte es probieren.
Wenn Experten es empfehlen,
finde ich es meistens sinnvoll,
auf sie zu hören.
Dafür gibt es Wissenschaftler
und Experten.
Menschen sterben. Man soll das ernst
nehmen und versuchen, mitzutragen.
Hallo.
- Ich weiss nicht ...
Ich kann nicht reisen
und nicht einkaufen.
Und darum müssen wir das machen.
- Ja.
Wenn ich eine andere Arbeit suche,
fragt der Chef vielleicht:
"Haben Sie die Impfung?"
Ich: "Nein."
Er: "Okay, nein, danke."
- Haben Sie davor Angst?
Ja.
- Okay.
Angestellte,
die sich unter Druck fühlen.
V.a. in der Pflege
ist das ein Thema.
Das Heim, das seinen Mitarbeitern
mit Kündigung droht,
falls sie sich nicht impfen lassen,
schweigt immer noch.
Warum setzt ein Arbeitgeber
sein Personal
wegen dieser Impfung
derart unter Druck?
Mittlerweile
liegt mir die Weisung vor,
welche Mitarbeiter vom Heim
erhalten haben.
Eine drastische Massnahme,
bis jetzt ohne offizielle Begründung
mir gegenüber.
Ich treffe Pflegende,
denen zwar nicht die Kündigung droht,
die aber wegen der Impfung
Stress bei der Arbeit haben.
Diese Pflegefachfrau
möchte anonym bleiben.
Was passiert bei Ihrem Arbeitgeber?
Das kam von oben,
von der Spitalleitung,
die sich mit Videobotschaften
an uns wendet.
Bis jetzt waren alle Impfungen
freiwillig. Jetzt ist es anders.
Ich werde dazu gedrängt, eine Inter-
vention an meinem Körper zu machen,
die wahrscheinlich
gegen meinen Willen geschehen wird.
Was macht die Impfung
mit der Gesellschaft?
Die Geimpften
sind die Guten, die Solidarischen.
Leute wie ich,
die das Impfen verweigern,
sind verantwortungslos und asozial.
Mit diesem Stempel habe ich Mühe,
denn das bin ich nicht.
Warum können Sie das
nicht öffentlich sagen?
"Weltverschwörer" kommt da sofort.
Ich bin absolut keine Impfgegnerin,
mein Impfstatus ist aktuell.
Aber mit diesem neuen Wirkstoff geht
es wirklich um eine andere Nummer.
Die Corona-Krise
polarisiert die Gesellschaft.
Mit Impfkritikern und Corona-Mass-
nahmen-Gegnern in Kontakt zu treten,
ist für mich beinahe
ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit.
Ich erhalte Absagen
mit der Begründung,
dass Medien wie das Schweizer Fern-
sehen nicht vertrauenswürdig seien.
Es gibt keinen Impfzwang.
Das ist sogar verboten im Gesetz.
Ein Impfobligatorium
ist etwas anderes.
Das Schweizer Fernsehen
gehöre zu den sog. Massenmedien
und mache Propaganda, sagt man mir.
Informationen
von Impf- und Corona-Kritikern
würden wir bewusst verzerren
und falsch wiedergeben.
Impfkritiker und Corona-Gegner
vernetzen sich online
und verbreiten dort ihre Botschaften.
Besonders beliebt:
der Messengerdienst Telegram.
Hier gibt es teils
krasse Falschmeldungen - ohne Zensur.
"'Die Wahrheit' -
von YouTube gelöscht".
Letztes Mal
konnten wir es noch sehen.
Techplattformen
greifen mittlerweile ein.
YouTube hat ein Video der sog. Frei-
heitlichen Bewegung Schweiz gelöscht.
Eine Gruppierung
sagt mir schliesslich zu.
Wir sind unterwegs an einen Ort,
der geheim bleiben muss.
Wir gehen zur Gruppierung
"Freunde der Verfassung".
Wir gehen in die Kampagnenzentrale.
Noch einmal. Hallo?
Hallo? Es ist das falsche Haus.
Das ist wirklich geheim,
wenn man nicht angeschrieben ist.
Hier ist auch nichts angeschrieben.
Wir irren umher.
Grüezi, Herr Bubendorf.
Ist das Absicht?
Wir können uns nicht anschreiben.
Wir kriegen Drohungen
von besorgten Bürgern.
Also müssen wir den Standort
geheim halten.
Was für Drohungen?
- Gegen uns als Personen.
Gegen Leib und Leben. Gegen ...
Ja, weil wir uns engagieren.
Das sehen nicht alle gerne.
Wir haben viele Unterstützer,
die das super finden.
Ich konzentriere mich mehr auf die.
Das sind Briefe und Zuschriften
von Leuten, die uns unterstützen
und uns in dieser hektischen Zeit
ganz viel Mut gemacht haben.
Was schreiben die so?
"Danke für Ihre grosse Arbeit.
Grüsse."
"Ihr seid unsere letzte Hoffnung."
Warum die letzte Hoffnung?
Es ist eine Situation,
die für viele sehr bedrohlich ist.
Was ist denn
das besonders Bedrohliche?
Dass wir in einem Staat leben,
der unser Leben bis
ins letzte Detail bestimmen möchte.
Der Verein "Freunde der Verfassung"
hat laut eigenen Angaben
mittlerweile 5'000 Mitglieder.
Schon bald
geht es in den Abstimmungskampf
gegen das sog. COVID-Gesetz.
Aktuell im Fokus:
die neue mRNA-Impfung.
Jetzt haben wir zu allem
noch ein neues Verfahren,
wo man in wenigen Monaten sagt,
dass es da sei,
es schütze
und sei auch völlig ungefährlich.
Langzeitwirkungen habe es keine.
Wie will man das nach einer Entwick-
lungszeit von fünf Monaten wissen?
Das wird nicht gesagt.
Die seien nicht bekannt.
Also,
es kann Langzeitwirkungen geben?
Nein, es sei nicht bekannt.
Das wird so gesagt.
Dass man verlangen kann,
sich einen Stoff zu impfen ...
Es wird ja nicht verlangt.
- ... von dem man nicht weiss,
ob und welche Langzeitwirkungen er
hat, ist für mich sehr übergriffig.
Der Staat verlangt das nicht.
Ja, genau,
Stand heute ist das noch nicht so.
Haben Sie Zulauf durch die Situation?
- Ja, das ist eindeutig so.
Wir haben uns gegründet, um etwas
gegen die Pandemiewillkür zu machen.
Viele Leute in der Bevölkerung
sind nicht einverstanden damit,
wie es läuft
und darum haben wir den Zulauf.
Ob wir davon profitieren ...
Ich freue mich auf nichts mehr,
als auf den Moment,
wo wir den Verein auflösen können,
weil wir unser Ziel erreicht haben.
Was sind denn da für Leute dabei?
Wir haben Leute aus
dem gesamten politischen Spektrum.
So, wie ich das beurteilen kann,
haben wir keine Extremen.
Die Leute, die ich kennenlerne,
sorgen sich alle um die Freiheit
und die Solidarität in der Schweiz.
Wo stehen wir denn?
Wir haben viel Freiheit verloren.
Warum?
Weil uns die Regierung sagt ...
... was wir dürfen und was nicht,
was vorher nicht der Fall war.
Absehbar?
Ihr Wort in Gottes Ohr.
Supersaxo ist mein Name.
Ich bin der Impfarzt.
Grüezi. Frau Bundi ...
- (Frauen) Grüezi.
Zurück
im Alters- und Pflegeheim Eigen.
Ist das gut?
- Ja, ist gut. Es ist interessant.
Nicht erschrecken,
es gibt einen kleinen Stich.
Auszuhalten?
Ja, ja.
- Gut, es ist fertig.
Vielen Dank.
- Gern geschehen.
In vier Wochen noch einmal, okay?
Gibt es eine Bilanz, Herr Supersaxo?
Die Bilanz ist eigentlich,
dass wir nach Plan arbeiten konnten.
Der Ablauf war gut organisiert.
Wir sind sehr zufrieden, danke.
Alle Bewohner
hätten die Impfung gut vertragen,
sagt mir später die Heimleitung.
Von den Pflegenden
will sich ein Drittel impfen lassen.
Lassen Sie sich impfen?
- Ich lasse mich impfen, ja.
Warum?
Weil ich mich für die Bewohner
verantwortlich fühle.
Auch wenn noch nicht klar ist,
ob es die Übertragung verhindert?
Wenn man gar nichts macht,
hilft es auch nicht.
Man kann von einer Viruserkrankung
auch langfristige Schäden haben.
Lassen Sie sich impfen?
- Nein.
Ich kann nicht sagen,
dass ich es nie mache.
Ich kann mich einfach im Moment
noch nicht dazu entschliessen.
Dürfen wir Sie auch fragen,
ob Sie sich impfen lassen?
Ich lasse mich impfen.
Ich mache heute die Corona-Impfung.
Ich bin nicht bereit.
Ich kann es nicht begründen.
Und bei Ihnen? Tun Sie es?
- Nein, ich impfe mich nicht.
Ist es ein grundsätzlicher Vorbehalt
oder wegen dieser Impfung?
Nein,
ich impfe mich grundsätzlich nicht.
Es ist schön,
dass wir die Freiheit haben,
selber zu entscheiden.
Wir haben keinen Druck.
Man darf auch wankelmütig sein.
Man kann sagen,
man entscheide sich noch nicht.
Aber vielleicht entscheidet man
in vier Wochen anders,
weil der Erfahrungsschatz
schon wieder ein anderer ist.
Innerhalb der Gesellschaft
glaube ich ...
... dass diese Impfung
die Befürworter und Gegner
wieder
massiv weit auseinandertreibt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass
diese Impfung jetzt wieder spaltet.
Ich habe Neuigkeiten vom Altersheim,
das seinen Mitarbeitern
mit der Kündigung gedroht hat.
Erst sah es danach aus, als würde das
Heim vor der Kamera Stellung nehmen,
doch dann kam alles anders.
Das Altersheim hat jetzt entschieden,
dass es vor der Kamera
nicht begründen wolle,
warum es Mitte Januar
ein Impfobligatorium
an sein Personal verschickt hat.
Es sagte den Leuten:
"Wenn ihr euch nicht impfen lasst,
gibt es eine Verwarnung
und dann eine Kündigung."
In einer schriftlichen Stellungnahme
schreibt mir das Heim später,
es möchte anonym bleiben -
aus Angst vor Übergriffen militanter
Corona-Skeptiker und Impfgegner.
Weiter schreibt die Heimleitung,
die Kündigungsandrohung
sei ein Fehler gewesen.
Dieser sei nun korrigiert.
Und übrigens:
Nur die Nicht-Impfwilligen
hätten dieses Schreiben erhalten.
Aber die Weisung bleibe bestehen:
Wer sich nicht impfen lasse,
müsse dies schriftlich begründen
oder mit einem Arztzeugnis belegen.
Diese einschneidende Massnahme
müsse das Heim treffen,
weil bereits viele Bewohner
an COVID gestorben seien.
Ob eine solche Weisung zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt rechtlich standhält,
ist völlig unklar.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Es ist momentan
einfach alles durcheinander.
Das ist einfach kein Leben, oder?
Keine Ahnung, es ist fast
wie eine kleine Depression.
Je länger je mehr
fühlen wohl recht viele wie ich:
Man möchte, dass es einfach aufhört.
Und wenn die Impfung
eine Möglichkeit ist,
das zu bewirken, ist das sicher
ein sehr grosses Argument dafür.
Hallo.
Ich glaube,
als Bürger muss man sich wie ...
... damit abfinden und sagen:
"Komm, wir hoffen,
dass die wissen, was sie machen."
Es scheint ja zu funktionieren.
Ich hätte gerne
ein volles Restaurant,
verstehen Sie mich nicht falsch.
Es wäre ein Traum,
wieder laute Musik zu haben,
alles voller Gäste zu haben,
Wein zu trinken, den Lärmpegel ...
Aber ich glaube, es ist jetzt
einfach nicht die Zeit dafür.
Danke und einen schönen Abend!
Tschüss!
Sollte die Impfung
tatsächlich ein Teil des Auswegs
aus dieser Pandemie sein,
scheint mir nach all den Begegnungen
klar:
Die gesellschaftliche Polarisierung
wird deswegen
nicht einfach verschwinden.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021